man who helped hide the murder of a
young woman will sit in jail for more
than another year 46-year-old jose
rangel was sentenced to a total of two
years in jail earlier today for his role
in the killing of leslie palacio joe
moller was in court he's live downtown
las vegas for what the palacio family is
now planning to do joe
the family of leslie palacio say they
are pleased that he got the maximum
sentence but they are not happy that is
the only thing that he's going to be
getting is two years here in this
courthouse say they wish he would have
gotten more they say their fight now is
not over jose rangel spoke via video to
the palacio family asking for
forgiveness we heard from 22 year old
leslie palacio's sisters and mother one
even brought leslie's ashes to the table
they described how hard it has been
since she died the judge not pleased
with what jose rangel had to say said
all she can do under the current law is
sentenced ronell to two years for being
an accessory to murder and hiding
evidence
very hard for us to
speak about how we feel
about leslie's case it was very
frustrating
seeing him trying to apologize us asking
for forgiveness knowing that he doesn't
mean it we're not forgetting leslie or
this case
our focus is
eric rangel
and
getting eric in custody
that is our biggest challenge right now
and that is where we will find our
justice
investigators believe it was ranell's
son eric who murdered leslie video shows
what appears to be the two moving her
body out of the family's home as eric
rendell is still at large the family is
now putting up ten thousand dollars for
information leading to his arrest they
also plan to create the leslie palacio
law to change the punishments for the
crimes jose committed the family says
they will not be giving up until eric
runhell is found now jose rendell will
serve a total of two years in clark
county detention center 205 days have
already been served reporting live in
downtown las vegas this evening joe
moore 8 news now